[MUSIC PLAYING]
DON DODGE: Hi.
I'm Don Dodge, and this is
Google Group Access.
Today, our topic is Best
Practices for Developing
Android Applications and How to
be Successful on the Google
Play Store.
My guest today is Reto
Meier, my colleague.
Reto's in charge of Android
developer relations.
Thanks for joining us.
RETO MEIER: Thank you.
DON DODGE: Reto, the number one
question I get everyday
is, how do I get my
app featured on
the Google Play store?
RETO MEIER: It's a
common question.
Absolutely.
With Google I/O coming up, I'm
expecting to hear a lot over
those few days.
I think it's an important
question because I think
that's fundamentally--
it's probably the biggest impact
you can have on making
your app more successful.
Having a lot more downloads is
getting into one of those
featured spots.
So it is a question
we get a lot.
And the answer is both simple
and quite complicated.
Really, what it comes down to
is building a great app,
something which our
merchandising team is going to
be able to look at and think,
this is something people are
going to really love.
This is something which
is going to
help promote our platform.
It's going to help encourage
people to buy Android devices
and really think great
things about what the
platform can achieve.
So that's the easy way.
It's also kind of a cheap answer
because it's like, OK.
A lot of people have
great apps.
What do we need to do to
go to that extra level?
And so I think fundamentally,
there's a few very specific
things you can do.
And the first is to make sure
that all of your Google Play
assets are there.
And that's kind of table
stakes to the game.
You need to have a great logo,
great feature graphic, all of
those assets which we ask for.
If you don't have them in your
Google Play listing,
we can't fix you.
It's just not possible.
So that's table stakes
to get into the game.
Beyond that, we actually have
two really great lists which
we've recently published, which
are "Best Practices for
Creating Quality Apps" and the
same guidelines for creating
quality tablet apps.
And they're both available
on developer.android.com.
And what they do is they break
down these check lists which
tell you exactly what our QA
teams are looking at in order
to decide whether an app is
viable for featuring.
So if you go through each of
those checklists and make sure
that you cover all those things,
then again, you're in
a great position.
So if you have a great app
with all the assets, and
you've gone through the
checklists, then you're in a
real position where you
have a really strong
chance of being featured.
DON DODGE: Where are those
checklists located?
How do I find them?
RETO MEIER: They're all on
developer.android.com on the
slash distribute tab.
DON DODGE: So developer.androi
d.com/distributor?
RETO MEIER: Distribute.
DON DODGE: Distribute.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
So we have three sections on
developer.android.com, one for
developers, one for designers,
and one for people
distributing apps.
And each has a huge amount of
data to help you build the
best apps you can, the best
looking apps you can, and then
distribute them as successfully
as possible.
And the Distribute tab is, I
think, something which is
something of an undiscovered
gem.
There's a lot of data there
which can help you really
promote your app, increase
your chances of being
featured, help your
chances of being
successful in Google Play.
DON DODGE: That's excellent.
So there's a section for
developers about best
practices for developing.
There's a section for designers
on how to design
great apps.
And then there's a section for
how to get distribution and
best practices there.
RETO MEIER: Exactly.
And I think in days gone by,
developer.android.com was
primarily for engineers, coding
types like myself, who
are more comfortable
sitting in code.
And over the years, as Android
has developed into the
ecosystem that it is now, it's
become increasingly important
to focus on those other
things, as well.
And so as that has come more to
the fore, we've put a lot
more effort in trying to
help people design
great looking apps.
Design in such a focus
these days.
I think for really no matter
what you're trying to build on
whatever platform, having that
great design can be the
difference between an app which
a few people enjoy and
which really is a breakout
success.
And then distribution is the
final cog in that wheel.
You know, you have a great
app that looks great.
How do you make it into
a successful business?
And that's the sort of stuff
that we're trying to highlight
and promote within the
Distribute tab.
DON DODGE: So let's assume that
the developer has done a
good job in developing the app
from a technical perspective.
Design is a little harder.
That's like I know a good
design when I see it.
But I couldn't describe it.
So how do you encourage
people?
What are some of the best
practices in design?
RETO MEIER: Yeah.
It's actually a really
good point.
And it's something which we
really try and encourage.
So what we have in the Design
tab is really a lot of
information around what are
the expectations around
building an app which looks
right on Android.
Now we don't want to get into
a situation where every app
looks the same.
That's boring.
That's not helping people
create new and really
interesting experiences.
So what we focus on is providing
a set of guidelines
which will make your
app look at home
within the Android ecosystem.
So that it will feel as though
it's a part of the system and
integrate well with all the
other apps running there.
So what we really encourage is
making sure that you don't
break any of those guidelines.
You don't institute any sort
of user experience actions
which are contrary to
what people expect.
For example, if they see tabs on
a screen, they're going to
expect to be able to swipe left
and right using a view
pager to move that content.
So if you don't do that, then
you introduce this cognitive
dissonance for your users.
They're going to expect
something to
work, and it doesn't.
Suddenly they lose confidence
in their
ability to use your app.
And that makes them less
inclined to use it.
So we say, don't break
the guidelines.
Create a consistent
experience.
But use that as a base, and
build on top of that to create
something as unique
as possible.
We really encourage people to
create apps, which are a
unique experience, which
showcase the content which
that app is delivering in
interesting and innovative
ways which fit within the
guidelines that we have.
DON DODGE: While we're on the
topic of design, is there a
difference between designing
an app for a mobile device
versus a tablet?
RETO MEIER: I think there is.
And it's a really good
way of looking at
it, as well, I think.
We try and encourage people
to have, if possible, one
distributable, which will work
on a variety of different
devices and work well.
And in terms of implementation,
often that's
not too big a challenge.
Where the real challenge comes
in is creating something which
works really well on phones and
tablets and any other kind
of form factor.
And with a lot of different
screen sizes, that can
introduce a challenge
in design.
Something which works very well
on a small phone may not
work as well on a tablet.
And so a big part of what we're
encouraging developers
to do today is take a look at
their app and think about how
will this work well?
How will this prevent a
better user experience
on a different device?
Particularly for tablets because
I think a lot of our
developers have come to Android
from that phone
experience.
And We have a bunch of tools
within the framework to make
sure that many phone apps will
scale up and work reasonably
well on tablets.
That's really just
the first step.
I think we're moving now to this
next stage where we want
them to build--
really design their
apps so that they
work great on tablets.
And mint.com is a fantastic
example of this, where they've
looked to see how the
users use our app on
tablets versus phones.
And so they have with one file
which they distribute two
complimentary experiences.
So on the phone, you're using it
to enter your expenses, all
of the things which you're
spending money while
you're on the go.
On the tablet, it's much more
of a browsing interface.
You're sitting down.
You're looking to see how
have I spent my money.
It's much more immersive.
It has a much longer
engagement.
And they've seen that from using
their analytics, finding
out how are people using the app
on different devices, and
then tailoring the experience
to maximize what people are
already doing on
those devices.
DON DODGE: So the difference
between mobile devices and
tablets, does it have to
do with design and user
experience?
Or are there actually, from an
engineering point of view,
different code that you have
for one versus the other?
RETO MEIER: Well that's one of
the beauties, I think, of the
way the Android framework
works is that from an
engineering perspective, no.
It's all the same
sort of code.
It's all using the same classes
and methods and
everything else.
You're just having to implement
another design.
And wherever possible, using
things like fragments, we try
to make that as seamless
as possible.
So you can create different
components, which are just
effectively arranged
differently.
In a lot of cases, it's
sort of first
past design for tablets.
It's simply removing a
layer of navigation.
So where on a phone, you
may have a list.
You click an item.
It drills down to
more content.
You click again.
It gives you more content.
On a tablet, particularly in
landscape mode, you have a lot
more screen real estate.
So you can have the
list on the left.
You click on it.
It'll have the detail panels
on the right hand side.
So you've got sort of
more on the screen.
But each of those components
are used in both layouts.
It's just a matter of laying
them out differently.
And wherever possible, the
Android framework tries to
make that as simple as it can.
DON DODGE: So a mobile device
is obviously quite different
than a tablet.
But even within mobile devices,
there are different
manufacturers, different
screen sizes,
that kind of thing.
How do you deal with that?
RETO MEIER: I think there's two
factors to consider there.
And one is we try and think
less about specific form
factors and more about
screen sizes.
So it's very similar to the way
that web development has
always worked.
You basically figure out what
layout is going to work and
how small you can make it until
you're going to have to
rethink the user interface
for something
that's easy to use again.
So much of the way we define it
is to say that you need to
have different layouts
for different
minimum screen widths.
And that can take care of a lot
of the variation within
particular categories.
As well as that, we also
like to think about--
I can't remember.
Can't remember where I
was going with that.
[LAUGHTER]
DON DODGE: So how many
applications have a good
tablet design?
Or what are some of those best
practices for tablets that
make it so much better on
a tablet and a different
experience from the
mobile device?
RETO MEIER: Right.
OK.
Yeah.
And that's excellent.
It actually prompts me to remind
me what I was going to
say as my second point, which
is responsive design.
It's a big part of that.
So you want to have something
which scales well so that if
there is any sort of variation
between different screen
sizes, you're going to have an
experience that looks right.
Things expand in the
right places.
You have white space in
the right places.
You don't end up with strange
empty things or really small
fonts or anything like that.
When it comes to creating that
great tablet design, well for
a start, we have, again, a
best practices guide on
developer.android.com for
creating great tablet apps.
And that talks about things
like making sure that you
don't have excessive
white space.
That you don't have text
which is too small.
That you have big enough
touch targets, all
these sorts of things.
And that's all, as I say,
detailed more specifically on
developer.android.com.
If are building for tablets,
definitely I recommend going
through that list again.
This is what we look at when
we're trying to figure out is
this an app which we think is
designed specifically for
tablets to highlight in
different collections on
Google Play and those
sort of things.
In terms of specifics, or I
should say, those that's sort
of the engineering specifics
more generally, looking for--
or we found that users tend
to find tablets in a more
engaging way.
So phones will be taken out of
your pocket, spend a couple of
minutes, put it back in.
Tablets are more
using casually.
On a couch, lying in bed,
whatever else, where you're
spending half an hour,
an hour at a time.
It's almost an alternative
to a laptop in many ways.
It's sort of an
easy-to-deal-with laptop.
So it's creating experiences
which
work within that context.
So richer user engagement,
longer periods of time.
You build your phone apps
expecting that users are going
to be interrupted constantly by
the people around them or
notifications coming in.
Just the day to day.
On tablets, it's a great
platform for things like media
consumption.
And you can design your app
using this same sort of
philosophy, like something which
people are going to be
able to sit down and
interact with for
significant periods of time.
DON DODGE: You mentioned
touch points just a
minute ago in design.
And I, this morning, had an app
where it was an HTML5 app.
It looked great on my laptop.
But when I went to use
it on my phone, I
had to check boxes.
And they were so close that I
couldn't check the right box.
So is that what you mean by
touch points and how to design
around those?
RETO MEIER: Yeah, absolutely.
It's one of the things which
we found with modern smart
phones and tablets is
that people use
their fingers to interact.
And this is a feature.
It's wonderful.
I had a phone back in the
day which had a stylus
touchscreen.
And that finger experience is
just a much better way to go.
But that does mean that
everything you need to click
needs to be about the size of
your finger, which an Android
is 48 dips, which is device
independent pixels.
So on every device, 48 dips is
the right amount of space for
your pointed finger
to touch things.
So that's a really
important point.
But in terms of how big the
buttons need to be and check
boxes, but also how much space
do you need to leave between
different touch targets?
So check boxes is
a great example.
You want to make sure when
someone clicks something,
they're clicking what
they want to.
As soon as someone does
something they didn't want to,
again, they lose confidence
in themselves, in the app.
They're less inclined
to use it.
I've always found that we tend
to be quite deeply engaged in
the tech world.
So the way we learn things is
you press all the buttons and
see what it all does.
Most people, that's not
quite how it works.
And a lot of people, and
remembering that smart phones
have been expanding so quickly,
that it's people who
used to own feature phones are
now entering into the world of
smart phones.
Maybe not comfortable with
computers as some of us more
techy people are.
They sort of approach it with
this feeling that if they
press things in the wrong order,
it's going to delete
everything and post nude photos
of them on the internet.
Not that there are any.
[LAUGHTER]
But somehow.
And so when you're dealing with
people have that sort of
hesitation around using
technology, you really need to
do everything you can to remove
that fear, to make them
feel comfortable.
So that anything they press,
it does something.
It doesn't predictable.
It does something
non-destructive.
It does something they can
take back if they weren't
happy with what they did.
And really try to make them feel
more comfortable with the
technology.
DON DODGE: Another question I
get every week is HTML5 versus
native app.
And that example I used earlier
was an HTML5 app that
worked great on a laptop.
But when I used it on a
phone, was unusable.
So it's a big debate.
But where do you come
out on that?
RETO MEIER: That's an
interesting topic.
And in fact, I gave a
presentation with Mike
Mahemoff from the Chrome team
a couple of years ago at
Google I/O, which tried to
tackle this exact topic.
And it was interesting.
And there was a lot
of interest.
A lot of people want
to know the answer.
And fortunately, or
unfortunately, there's no
silver bullet.
I think in an ideal world, and
I think Google is a good
example of this, you do both.
And you make sure both
are really good.
I think these days it's
shortsighted to think that you
can have a web presence, which
if someone goes to on a
browser, doesn't look good
on whatever device they
happen to be using.
On the other hand, there are
certain advantages to building
native apps, which just
can't be done on web
browsers right now.
So if you're building apps
which have media content,
which you want them to be
faster, smoother, feel more a
part of the device, native
apps create a really--
an optimal experience.
So I mean I'm on the
Android team.
So obviously I don't exactly
have a completely independent
perspective on this.
But I think that you can create
a much better, richer
experience building a native
app for Android.
But I think it's also worth
investing the time and effort
to make sure your mobile
experience is fantastic on
every platform, as well.
DON DODGE: Right.
So native apps have
a few advantages.
One is your logo for the app
appears on the phone screen,
whereas if you're a website,
then you have
to navigate to it.
It doesn't appear
on your phone.
So that's one.
Another is native apps can send
notifications or messages
to the top deck.
And HTML5 web apps
can't do that.
RETO MEIER: Yeah.
DON DODGE: Right?
Those are two obvious ones.
Are there others?
RETO MEIER: I think a lot of the
biggest advantages is you
get from native sort of
fall into two camps.
One is just the advantages
you get from being
closer to the metal.
You know, you don't have an
additional interpreter between
you and the device hardware.
So things can just be
faster and smoother.
DON DODGE: So performance
is better?
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
I mean, and it makes
sense, right?
If you're running on top of a
browser, that's just another
app, another layer, between you
and the hardware, which
needs to do processing
and rendering.
So you really want to have that
buttery smooth, beautiful
animations.
Everything happening quickly.
You're going to be better off
trying to have as little
between you and the hardware
as possible.
The other side is more the
ability to be much more deeply
immersed within the ecosystem
on the device.
Android was designed right from
day one to make sure that
each app was carefully sandboxed
for security
reasons, but then have a bunch
of really good controlled ways
that you can then share
information between apps.
So things like sharing, so you
can share something from
within your app and take
advantage of every other app
on the device which is able to
share that kind of content.
Those sorts of advantages, I
think, are quite significant.
The ability to get into the
content providers of the app
to be able to launch maps, all
of those sorts of things,
which really deeply embed your
app as part of that whole
ecosystem of the device is
something that you can't do if
you're within your own
sandbox on a browser.
DON DODGE: Or if your app
utilizes the camera on the
phone, or utilizes
the GPS or the
accelerometer or other things.
Those are some examples where
you'd want to go to native
versus HTML.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
It's an interesting point
because I think it's sort of
the most visible thing right
now, but also the thing where,
I think, the web is
going to catch up.
The advantages on if you're
building sort of natively,
then you have access to every
sense as soon as it's
available on the device.
So we introduced a barometer
a couple of releases ago.
And obviously if the hardware
is in there, you've got APIs
to be able to access it.
I think what will happen over
time is the more senses become
standardized, then HTML5 is
going to start introducing web
API to access that and cameras,
GPS, and compasses,
three of the things which have
already made their way into
the HTML5 spec.
I think we'll continue to see
that as the senses get more
and more standardized.
But again, if you want to use
something new, then you're
going to have to
use the native.
DON DODGE: So HTML5 is catching
up and being able to
access these different features
on the phone.
But your answer is you
need to do both well.
RETO MEIER: I think so.
I think if you really want to be
successful, if you want to
have an app which is
able to reach the
biggest audience possible.
And I think in terms of success,
that's fundamental.
You want to make sure your app
is usable by everyone who
would be interested.
You can't go wrong
by doing both.
I think the real challenge
is figuring out
which do you do first.
And for me, again, I think build
native is going to be
able to have that smoothest,
richest experience.
And then have web as a back up
to that for people who are
running on different platforms,
which maybe you
don't support directly, or just
have landed there from
the web page rather than
downloading your app from
Google Play.
DON DODGE: So let's talk a bit
more about distribution.
Of course, everyone wants to
have their app featured.
We talked a little
bit about that.
But a very small percentage
can be featured.
So what are some of the other
things that you can do, like
getting reviews?
What are some best practices
on getting reviews?
And what should you try to do?
RETO MEIER: Sure.
I think, again here, the easy
answer is build a great app
that people love to talk about,
which, again, is a
cheeky answer, but a really
important first start.
I think beyond that, it's
interesting to see, I think,
the fact that Android has
opened up, or mobile, in
general, has opened up this new
world of opportunity for
developers to be able to build
apps and distribute them to a
worldwide audience without
having to go
through a middle man.
And so a lot of us aren't
necessarily as experienced
with OK, so I have
this product.
I've launched it in this
worldwide marketplace.
How do I get people to notice?
And actually, a lot of the old
school techniques work really,
really well here.
Sending out press releases,
using standard marketing
techniques.
So two of the most effective
techniques that we've seen
from developers is using
surprise, surprise, online
advertising.
So things like at AdWords from
Google or AdMob, or similar
things from competitors.
Basically anything which is
going to put your app in front
of people for a relatively
low cost.
I think Google's done a pretty
good job of demonstrating that
online advertising works.
It works pretty well.
And it works really well
for apps also.
So I think that's definitely
something to invest in.
And I think that's fundamentally
the decision you
need to make.
You can either go through free
online channels, all the
social media, all the things
which are really
good practice there.
And if you decide that,
you know what?
I want to take it to
that next level.
I really want to get
eyeballs on there.
Then you need to consider
investing money.
And that means marketing.
That means advertising.
DON DODGE: I was using
an app last week.
And all of a sudden, in the
process of using the app, it
popped up a screen and said,
post a five star review of
this app and click here.
I didn't click it.
But can you do that?
Can you have a user
automatically
do a five star review?
RETO MEIER: So that's
a good question.
Happily, no.
You can't.
So it is something which a
lot of developers have--
well maybe not a lot.
But it's certainly an avenue
that some developers have
taken to basically ask for a
review within their app.
And I think there's a couple
risks with that and a couple
of best practices and
things to avoid.
And The risk is alienating
your users.
You know, if you ask them at the
wrong time, then they may
go and write your app, but not
give you the writing that you
were hoping for.
Or then they just see it as a
form of pop up advertising,
even if the advertising is for
the game you're playing.
It's like, oh, you're
getting in my face.
You're asking me
for something.
I just want to play this game.
To hell with it.
I'm going to uninstall it
and play something else.
So you risk that.
So one of the best practices is
making sure that if you do
do it, you can't ask for
a five star rating.
That's actually against
the terms of
service for Google Play.
So you can ask your users
to rate your app.
But you can only ask them to
write it and write it fairly.
You can't solicit a
five star review.
You certainly can't
incentivize a five star review.
So anything which says, do
this in order to get
something, that's a no-no.
Anything which says,
give us a five star
rating, also a no-no.
If you do choose to ask for an
honest review, so one of the
best practices is to make
sure that you're not
doing it too much.
Not every time they
open the app.
Certainly not the first time,
which is the oddest, right?
You've just installed the app.
You've opened it, and it says,
go and rate us in Play.
I haven't used it yet.
How could I do that?
So do it sensibly.
And I think one of the best
approaches I've seen is that
after you've used it for a
while, after you put in a few
hours worth of game play or
whatever else, at that point
you've got a user who you know
uses the app or the game.
They use it a lot.
Presumably that means
that they like it.
And you haven't said anything
to them before hand.
So you just ask them as a one
off at some point, hey, it
seems like you like it.
Maybe go and rate it?
That tends to have the
best response.
DON DODGE: I've heard of
developers who unintentionally
or through an honest mistake
got their app in trouble,
where they incentivized someone
to write a review or
they said, click on these three
adds to do something.
Or they did things that
seemed OK to them.
But they got in the penalty
box and had to
dig their way out.
What are some of those things
that, you call them no-nos,
but really don't do this?
RETO MEIER: Yeah, I would
definitely to anyone who has
an app in Google Play or is
planning to launch one to
really read through the
content policies, the
developer distribution agreement
in the attached
content policies, because
everything there, we mean it.
So these are the things which
we have teams which will go
through and make sure that the
apps in Google Play are
following those guidelines.
So some of the things, I guess,
I think the things
which people find the most
surprising is they will assign
their own assumed priorities
to these things.
So they'll see this list of
things they can't and they
shouldn't do.
And they'll go, well this one
is obviously important.
This one doesn't seem like
it's such a big deal.
They're all such a big deal.
There isn't really a prioritized
list where some of
them, it's fine and you can get
away with it, and others
are a definite strike.
So make sure that you're
complying with all of them.
Some of the examples which I've
seen most commonly-- so
I'll get asked a lot, well
my app got suspended.
Why?
I'm not on the team, which
actually will go through and
do those analyses.
And generally, I don't even
need to ask them.
I'll just look at their Google
Play listing, and it'll be
things most commonly like
putting lots of key words spam
into their description, using
competitor names, either--
sometimes it's to try
and be deceptive.
Often, it's not.
They're just doing it
as a sort of subtle
form of keyword spam.
Like, if you liked games like
Angry Birds and Temple Run,
then you'll love our game,
and that sort of thing.
It's like I could see you're
trying to be subtle.
It's not working.
[LAUGHTER]
RETO MEIER: In fact, you're
doing two things wrong there.
Really, if you don't have
permission from a copyright
holder to use their name, their
brand within your name
or description, then
don't do it.
And similarly, don't stuff a
whole bunch of keywords, don't
try and weave all those
keywords into a clever
paragraph because you
think that's subtle.
None of that works.
It needs to be a good and
accurate description, and an
honest description, of what the
app is and what it does.
DON DODGE: Excellent.
I've heard from other developers
who their app got
suspended and they
don't know why.
And I tell them well, did
you change anything?
Sometimes they have.
Sometimes they haven't.
Other times, it's they did
one of these don't dos.
But it wasn't caught
immediately.
It could be a week or a month
or some time later.
So is that fairly common?
RETO MEIER: Yeah, absolutely.
I mean the way that Google Play
works, we don't prefilter
any apps which go into
Google Play.
As everyone knows, it's one of
the features is you press
Publish, it goes through the
system, and it will be up
within an hour or so.
Which means that there is always
going to be a time
disparity between anything that
you're doing wrong and
someone noticing it.
Now for a lot of these more
obvious content policy
violations around inappropriate
content that
gets flagged really, really
quickly, malware will get
flagged even before
it goes live.
So most of that will be stripped
out and removed
before anyone ever
has to see it.
For some of the things which are
a little bit more subtle,
like keyword spamming or using
competitor names, it's usually
going to be when someone
notices.
Either it will be someone in our
team which discovers it or
it may be by virtue of the fact
that a lot of users are
flagging it, or just that it's
getting more popular.
So it's definitely something
which can happen either
immediately or over time.
Hopefully, that time span
is as short as possible.
DON DODGE: How should a
developer measure success when
developing an app or
on the app store?
RETO MEIER: That's a really
good question.
I think it's one of the things
which we look at
internally, as well.
Like how--
In the developer relations
team, we have to ask
ourselves, we want to make
developers successful.
So what does that mean?
How do we know that
we're doing a good
job at helping them?
And I think it really
comes down to what
is valuable to you.
What are you trying to achieve
by having your app
distributed?
Revenue is obviously one
metric that a lot
of people are using.
But a lot of apps are free.
They don't have any revenue
to speak of.
So what does successful
look like to them?
And that could be anything from
getting a lot of users,
or it can be something like
getting a greater engagement.
Maybe they've already got
something successful, and
they're now on mobile.
And they want to make sure
that their mobile user's
having a rich, immersive
experience.
They've got a static
user base.
And they want to now expand into
mobile to build a whole
bunch of new users.
So really I think it's important
to figure out why
are you launching this app?
What will it mean for you
to be successful?
How will you be able to sit back
at the end of the day and
say, that was worth the
time and effort?
We've done something
worthwhile.
And so I think the key there,
as well, is once you've made
that decision, is figure
out how to measure it.
Revenue's really easy because
you can just look at your bank
account and see whether or not
the money's coming in.
Other things require a little
bit more effort, particularly
things like engagement.
And then using tools like Google
Analytics for mobile is
a really great way
of doing that.
You can see how people are using
your app, are they doing
the things which you want them
to be doing on your app for it
to be successful?
DON DODGE: So write a great app,
write a good description,
get good reviews, get
lots of downloads.
In featuring an app, how
important is number of
downloads versus number of
reviews versus do they use the
latest feature?
Is this something--
so what kinds of
things get more important?
RETO MEIER: I think pretty
much everything
goes into the buckets.
When the merchandising team
are looking to decide what
they want to highlight, they're
going to look at
pretty much anything
that they consider.
And sometimes it's going
to be timely, like
Christmas is coming up.
So we're going to be looking
at apps which we think are
going to be popular over
the Christmas period.
Either Christmas themed or
through our analytics, we
found these sorts
of things that--
these sorts of apps are the ones
which people are looking
for at this time.
You know, really it comes down
to, in terms of downloads, it
can be either.
So obviously, we want
to highlight apps
which are very popular.
But at the same time, we want
to download apps which we
think people will love and they
just haven't seen yet.
So download count isn't really
a strong factor.
Quality is.
So you want to make sure
that you've got a good
high average rating.
Something around the four stars
at least, I think, is a
good place to start.
If you don't, find out why.
There's nothing to say that just
because-- you know, maybe
you launched early, got a
few things wrong, got
a lot of bad reviews.
You've turned things around
and started to improve it.
We can see that, as well.
But certainly, you want to be
getting as high a star rating
as possible through legitimate
means, of course.
DON DODGE: Cool.
So write a great app, write an
accurate listing, get good
reviews, take advantage of new
features, use advertising and
other methods to promote
your app.
That's five topics.
Are there any other things?
Or are those the major ones you
really want to focus on?
RETO MEIER: I think those
are the main ones.
I think the two other things
I'd want to highlight is to
really aim for app quality.
There are hundreds
of thousands of
apps in Google Play.
And you need to find
a way to stand out.
And the minimum bar for that
is to really make sure that
you have a good quality app.
So really looking at the app
quality guidelines, looking at
the tablet app quality
guidelines, and making sure
that you've got an experience
that works really well for all
of the users across all of the
different devices in the
ecosystem, I think, are the key
things you need to look at
to be successful
in Google Play.
DON DODGE: So all of those
guidelines are available on
the Google Play store or
to the developers?
RETO MEIER: Yeah, they're
all available on
developer.android.com.
Yeah, absolutely.
DON DODGE: So
developer.android.com is the
place to go.
RETO MEIER: Where
you want to go.
Absolutely.
If you've got nowhere else,
that is the place.
It's a hefty site, but there's
definitely all of the
information that you could need
or want to be able to be
more successful in
Google Play.
DON DODGE: So I've not read the
distribution agreement.
But is it a couple of
pages or 20 pages?
RETO MEIER: It's a few pages.
I think, yeah, a couple
of pages.
I think at Google, we try and
keep things in as plain
English as we possibly can.
And I think we've done a
reasonable job there.
DON DODGE: So I think you
suggested read that
distribution agreement carefully
because every line
there is important.
You can't ignore one of these
suggested don't-dos because it
will eventually hurt you.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
And to be fair, I've spoken
to a lot of developers.
And I haven't had that many
people who I've bumped into
which have accidentally
done something wrong.
So it's definitely something you
need to be aware of, but
not anything which
I think is--
this there's nothing there which
is to onerous or too
unexpected.
But as with anything, if
you're entering into an
agreement, it pays to understand
exactly what you're
agreeing to.
DON DODGE: And on the other
hand, it does make sense to
spend the time reading the best
practices because they
really can help you--
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
DON DODGE: --get distribution.
RETO MEIER: I mean, this is
the surprising thing.
It's like, we have a cheat sheet
on the site which tells
you all the things you need to
do to build an app which
people are going to really love
and people are going to
be engaged with.
So the cheat sheet is there.
So if you go through and you
look at all of those details,
and you those all into practice,
you're really going
to have an app which we're more
likely to feature, which
users are more likely to
download and more likely to
keep on using and talk about in
social media and give you
high ratings.
It all really flows
in on itself.
DON DODGE: So that
website again?
Where do you go to
get all this?
RETO MEIER:
Developer.android.com.
DON DODGE:
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
DON DODGE: Excellent.
Well this has been a
great discussion.
I really appreciate your time.
And thank you all
for joining us.
And I hope you'll be with
us next time on
Google Developers Live.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]